um
good morning we'll call the meeting to
order
um we'll seat
representative shut for
representative hatch and representative
tucker for representative lang
motion by mcguire ii by schmidt
any additions deletions or corrections
to the minutes
seeing none all in favor
okay
any request to remove anything from the
consent calendar saying none all was in
favor
okay motioned by mcguire to postpone
and would you like to speak to your
motion
yes mr chair i'd like to postpone this
the objection response is totally
inadequate and i would think the
department needs another couple of weeks
to come up with something that'll meet
and they should also probably be in
attendance
so all is in favor and postponement
hi
any
any objections
board of pharmacy
mr chairman
this is a
2021-122
there is a conditional approval request
the only issue is on page five it's a
note to jail car
so oplc is responsible for promulgating
rules to establish fees which they have
done so in plc 1000
so the fee mentioned on the conditional
approval request here for the board of
pharmacy on page five of the conditional
approval request
references that plc1000 and the fee set
in plc 1002.23
for the mail of order pharmacies is set
at two thousand dollars it was
established in an emergency role
and then um
updated in an interim role but the
interim rule expires on march 21st and
as of now the oplc has not um
or we have not received a filing from
oplc for a regular rule for this um
plc1000 and so the committee may have
questions about the expiration of this
fee
good morning tina kelly from the office
of professional licensure and
certification
and um it is my understanding that oplc
will be filing
good morning mr chair members of the
committee for the record lindsey coury
executive director office of
professional licensure and certification
um
we have had these rules the plc 1002s
drafted since i believe september and
our intent was to file them in november
with the idea that we would have
anticipated legislative changes
unfortunately when we sought
the consultation and collaboration with
the various licensing boards we've
received significant pushback from a
handful
which resulted in a significant delay in
us filing rules and ultimately we
decided to pare down those rules and
only file the rules that are absolutely
necessary
we recognize that this will result in
a
a a time period in which we will not
have a rule in place and obviously are
not able to charge people um but
unfortunately that that was the result
of uh having to collaborate with 54
different sets of boards with different
ideas as to
fees
comments
no more comments for me okay questions
yeah i'm just curious how you plan to
deal with the rush of of licensed
applications or you'll be receiving next
week
in terms of the fees
so right now we don't have fees in place
for i think it was vets veterinarians
and there may be one other that we don't
have fees in place
so
because of this issue that has been
ongoing for many years as to
disputes
as to who has authority to file fees
regarding
our rules regarding fees and what the
fee should be how the fee should be
allocated
and so right now we're just processing
the applications without charging a fee
which is obviously concerning because
that means that certain certain boards
are not meeting their costs the way
we've sought to remedy this was through
sb
which was intended to do a couple of
things clarify that oplc has the fee
setting authority which is the
legislation i think that we've discussed
previously with this committee
unfortunately again we received some
significant pushback from
several of the associations and boards
and so ultimately that bill has been
amended by the committee i think as of
last week senate ways and means
to essentially
create a study committee to study the
issue of fees
and how fees should be
or cost to be allocated so there is
going to be another delay unfortunately
that will mean that several of our
licensing boards or individuals within
our licensing boards are continuing to
pay well above 125
and some are not meeting costs
unfortunately i think that's just you
know that's the way the cookie crumbles
when we have to
see collaboration and consensus and we
anticipate having this worked out
hopefully next legislative session
so to answer your question
representative schmidt they essentially
will um
so what are our options
well the committee could vote to approve
the rule or the conditional approval
request
um
based on the note to gel card it doesn't
appear that there is a basis for
objection
go ahead carol how many
out-of-state pharmacies are you do you
license
representative i'm sorry i don't know
the number off the top of my head i will
say that the renewal schedule is not
until december so while we may receive
application new applications i don't
move to approve
second
motion by mcguire second by gray
discussion
seeing none
all those in favor
dealing with the renewal and
reinstatement requirements for nursing
licenses
adopted
issued by the governor last november
licensed healthcare professional boards
are supposed to
direct
are directed to identify all tools
available to streamline licensing
increase eligibility and implement other
strategies that will assist the health
ms courtney can certainly correct me but
i think there have been about 22 000
licenses
issued
since last year
the question i have here well let me
explain this issue first
currently
all applicants for renewal or for
reinstatement
have to show that they've been active in
practice practice
if they have not been active in practice
then they have to go through a program
through oplc
the emergency rule would limit the
active and practice requirements to only
those who have not held a license for at
the board thinks this will expedite
reinstatement of nursing professionals
my question is is there a real emergency
here since the pandemic seems to be
waning at least temporarily
and 22 000 licenses have been issued so
i'm not sure whether this
falls under the need for an emergency or
good morning again for the record
lindsey courtney executive director
office of professional ace insurance
certification i'm here um today
representing the board of nursing with
respect to its emergency filing
i think that there are probably two
different issues here i think there's
certainly the pandemic is winding down
but i think that we are in a real
emergency as it relates to healthcare
workforce that's separate and distinct
from
the big endemic and we were seeing that
obviously prior to coven i think it was
exacerbated due to covid
but we are still seeing a significant
issue with respect to workforce
i think it's due to a number of factors
obviously people getting burned out
during covid
but obviously our aging population in
new hampshire and it's clear that we do
not have a
significant or sufficient number of
health care workforce individuals in
order to meet our needs
so i think with that said the board of
nursing decided to pursuant to the
governor's executive order utilize the
tools available in his toolkit we i
believe were the only state
that required this active and practice
requirement for those renewing this was
a significant barrier and has been a
significant barrier particularly for
individuals who may leave the workforce
for a couple years let's say
to raise a child or to care for a sick
loved one
they would have to undergo a re-entry
program
that was essentially non-existent it was
incredibly difficult for people to find
a valid re-entry program so essentially
prevented people from re-entering the
workforce
and given the fact that the state
was
the only one to require this requirement
the board of nursing felt that
it was
not necessary and given the workforce
challenges we have that it was an
emergency and they promulgated this
emergency role
thank you mr chair um thank you um miss
courtney so
the if there isn't
some kind of formal training program
reentry program this will
just for the trust of the public the
responsibility will fall on the
employers so hospitals nursing homes
health care practices
do
are they going to have competency pro i
mean it's kind of outside of your
purview but what's your knowledge of
this are they going to be taking on
the competency and basically onboarding
these folks
yeah so this would only be limited to
individuals who've been out of the
workforce for five years or less
the board felt comfortable that within
five years
you'd be able to reenter the workforce
the employer could assess your
competency skills as they were required
to do anyways you could receive
continuing education but they didn't
feel that it was necessary to require
the individual to take the nclex again
for example and or go through a re-entry
program which is pretty
extensive after the five years they
would have to do that
in order to re-enter the workforce
okay representative mcguire
yes thank you i just wanted to confirm
that the continuing education
requirements for license still apply
correct
okay thank you
this is uh 2021-17
and there is an amended conditional
approval request
which has eliminated all staff
comments
move to approve
second
motion by maguire second by hatch
and any discussion
all those in favor
aye aye aye
opposed
and the department of health and human
services
this is another emergency rule we just
received it
on wednesday
the department is adopting the emergency
rule on involuntary emergency admissions
to designated receiving facilities
or to the new hampshire hospital
on may of last year may 13th last year
the governor issued executive order
2021-9
it directed
because of mental health crisis in the
state it directed
dhhs to create emergency rules
to immediately increase access to
services in order to address the mental
health crisis
it includes requirements for policies
and standards by which a hospital must
treat patients with mental health
concerns
these rules
are specific to
emergency admissions involuntary
admissions they're about 10 pages long
and there's about 10 pages of forms
i note that it's been 10 months since
the order came out from the governor
but given this topic of these rules
it's a legal nightmare and i can
understand where it would take a long
time to
do this
i did have a concern about whether there
should be
more specific statute
regarding emergency admission but
christina has pointed out that there is
indeed a statute regarding this
so
representative maguire
yes thank you i just wanted to confirm
that the department is starting into
regular rulemaking so these emergency
rules don't expire on us
good morning allison zeno administrator
of the administrative rules unit for the
department of health and human services
um yes we've actually as of yesterday we
have started uh working on initial
proposal draft to ensure nothing expires
questions from the committee
mr chairman i'd like to ask allison
whether uh
you anticipate having your
regular rules ready in time
yes we anticipate um we've already been
working with stakeholders um we
anticipate we've started our um initial
proposal draft internally um so yes we
100 plan on having these ready in time
before the expiration
september
okay
any other questions from the committee
thank you
mike anything else we have no other
business
seeing as we have no other business this
meeting
and this meeting is adjourned
whatever
could be misinterpreted
and that's why i want to put the whole
boat on there
and
you